uh welcome back and uh
the continued coverage of round five of
ultibox uh
the 2020 tournament is here hopefully
and uh we've been talking almost
exclusively about the
uh do the carson game because there were
a lot of developments there but there's
also a very sharp position on the board
in the
uh koran iranian game and they did they
did reach the position we were
discussing
uh some time ago levon after
some thought did end up playing after
bish p3 the sequence f5
g6 bishop takes ef rook takes
and uh yeah i think this might be this
might be playable for black i don't see
any immediate refutation yeah
me too let's think let's think what can
be
why it's uh uh plan here of course
knight g3 is an option
but uh again yeah it
doesn't seem to be so clear i mean
humanly of course queen d2 looks like
a very solid uh healthy move but maybe
black will
go knight c6 then yeah i think so yeah
and then if g495
uh is coming and that might be uh
[Music]
pretty uh uncomfortable
uh 22 22 played in the mean so
uh fabi fabi did choose this yeah knight
c6 seems like the most
uh the most natural move in the position
uh as you mentioned
creating the idea of 95 next move
i don't know if g4 is working still i
have big doubts but it has to be checked
g495
um so knight c6
yeah there's uh
as you can probably guess there is a
little bit of an issue
uh i don't know why i'm laughing it's
it's really no
no laughing matter because this is such
an interesting position and discussing
it without actually making moves on the
board
is going to be difficult but so let's
move maybe to the position of
if paul if you can manage it if you're
tired because that one is more
positional yeah we can
actually talk about it yeah they're not
sure many lines so
sure uh what is going on there in this
typical italian i was
i was wondering about the the decision
by by ferruja to play deforester early
because i think
uh it's not always that they that they
do this right sometimes
uh instead of g4 i think there's there's
an argument to be made
to try to play knight f1 bishop p3 and
so on yeah
let's let's say we go uh when we go
knight f1
uh and then and then we yeah we i would
like to trade this bishop
before peter but from other point of
view another idea for white in such
positions
is kind of to block this bishop yeah so
let's say d4
uh i mean let's check yeah now maybe b5
and trying to go knight c4 b6 is really
trying to
uh to get him out of play this bishop
but
of course it's uh yeah i mean black
might get a lot of
uh i mean quite a serious counter play
on the
on the kin side again yeah i think i
think that's a huge question if you have
enough time for this
trying to go knight h5 knight f4 g6 and
that is uh
it can get extremely sharp yeah the
position
so i don't know if uh d4 no but that's
quite logical knight g6 so now it's time
for a
very serious decision yeah for white and
other options unsurprisingly uh i think
alireza has been taking i think maybe
for the first time in this game he's
been taking
uh some serious time on this move
because
uh yeah it's not it's not clear how he
should proceed here another one knight
g3 still looks logical but
yeah it's it's an option though so what
after knight f1
or maybe knight h5 is a is an idea
trying to stop knight g3
another idea is probably trying to
attack the e4 pawn
to press not really to attack but to
press the e4 pawn
but or also a very typical idea is to
play d5
i mean maybe d5 can work yeah maybe even
the immediate g5
sometimes sometimes works in those
positions knight f1
t5 it takes d5 for example
and the queen d5 c4 very very
uh complicated position yeah it becomes
it becomes very concrete straight away
uh the moment
some kind of some kind of a clash in the
center starts you you have to calculate
variations and you have to be very
precise
uh not entirely sure what i think about
this uh
i feel like if i were playing this
mission with black i'd be quite happy
about g4 because i think it gives me
targets for counter play i think the
biggest problem black has in this
structure in general
is that if white plays slowly you just
don't quite know what to do with your
life you're just sitting there playing
on your
back you know three uh three ranks and
you
you shuffle and you shuffle and you
shuffle and there's still no prospects
yeah and i this i mean my game with
magnus was very
educational in this sense so he had a
little
even better version than that with white
here change these bishops and
i was really suffering i miraculously
managed to draw in this
last invitational tournament but it was
little fun
so uh but d4 okay now
again i would probably consider if i was
white to
to try to play b5 instead of knight f1
yeah knight f1 is of course is an option
obvious yeah let's let's take a look at
your plan yeah let's uh
let's see if uh let's say before you can
do this yeah
i'm not even sure if i'm supposed to
react because b takes a6 is probably not
something
yeah i don't know it probably doesn't
matter that much i mean if you take a b
a b or key e8 or you don't take
maybe i don't know about rookie 8 yeah
well it stops knight c4 the the reason
to play this move would be to
kind of tie your uh tie your knight on
g2 to the defense of the e4 square
stopping your declared intention and
maybe white can try to go
d5 now can hit e5 let's say rook 67
knight c4 yeah
trying to to get b6 yeah i wanted to go
bishop c5 of course
uh and uh yes that's logical now you
want b6 so i have to try b6 myself
probably
yeah and this is you know if if this
goes poorly for white it could go really
poorly right yeah
sure sure it is it is a quite a risky
uh play i would say but or another
option yeah d5 of course is positionally
quite risky uh yeah what are the other
ideas maybe
b6 uh also was possible
i have my doubts but b6 bishop takes b6
and then d5 knight c4
let's uh let's take a look yeah uh so
you go g5
knight c5 i guess eddie yeah so yeah 84
84
knight c4 but i think there is really a
question
how much how much have you actually
achieved here yeah yeah it is a question
it's just that
this looks only 78 a bit uh
yeah a bit strange but
who knows i mean there is i mean i think
white wants knight a5 knight c6
potentially so maybe black wouldn't
play it okay a little bit awkward yeah i
would like to play something like queen
c8 followed by c6 but maybe i'm not in
time maybe you
you do get to maybe to me looks like a
reasonable move yeah that's that's a
good move yeah that's a very good move
you stop you stop knight a5
okay then maybe queen c8 c6 yeah yeah
you can
prepare to play i think somewhere uh
let's try to analyze it a bit more
because okay i'm italian player i like
this position i've played it a lot so
actually with both colors with white and
with black
exactly this variations variation as
well
so after uh yeah
knight f1 or what else what what can we
uh what else can we do here
yeah the question knight f1 yeah it
makes of course a lot of sense i'm just
not sure about
yes d5 maybe doesn't work d5 yeah
because ed5
queen takes d5 c4 that looks uh
c4 questions probably the the thing that
worries me the most here
queen c6 b5 very important yeah queen c6
trying to go
d5 knight takes d5 well first of all
probably you can just take the pawn on
e5 but also b5
yeah b5 b5 is uh is maybe even stronger
because
so maybe maybe d5 doesn't work yeah
then it means i would say
probably knight h5 is an interesting
option we could like if we wanted to
make d5 work maybe we do it this way we
go
ah but then maybe you played d5 yeah d5
knight g3 and then those rooks uh
yeah because yeah this is this is
awkward
neither five is a is a very big threat
here yes the bishop on a7 is now very
beautiful but
uh yeah you have to solve it but uh i've
played once again with rajabov in this
line and then
this bishop was quite beautiful up to
the moment i
managed c4 c5 and then then it became
much less beautiful
uh somehow yeah yeah that is that is
true yeah if it gets locked down there
it's not going to be much fun
uh so why not knight f1 i wonder because
i think
knight fan is probably the most the most
natural the most yeah
i i think knight h5 yeah knight h5 would
be my
my choice here right and maybe even rook
f6 in some position yeah sometimes for
f6 or this idea knight gf4 rg6 yeah it
can really become
dangerous i mean if i manage it
even if it's uh quite difficult usually
you have to
to manage to create a real attack there
so let's say bishop e3
for white and
[Music]
knight gf4 maybe what i think we play
i think we need to check if this works
because uh
sometimes those those ideas do work and
then they are quite devastating like gtx
e5
yeah rook g6 might might already be very
bad for
yeah maybe i would i would after knight
f4 i would consider knight g3 in h2
something very solid you know just to
to secure my king somehow maybe knight
g3 here but i think i'm taking i think
i think i'm going to claim that this is
not
good for white structurally is it
if i don't think they can go back yeah
but yeah you're right you're right it's
not
perfect but who knows maybe it's not too
bad uh either i mean
like uh
you want what you want to take on d4
probably i think now i want to take on
d4 because the pawn only 4 can no longer
be supported by f3 yeah because probably
keen h2
seems to be a logical move yeah and i
don't see anything really more
i mean better than ed4 here i think i'm
taking if you give me the chance i'm
taking on g4 and going from there yeah
still i don't know cd4 i'm not
completely sure yeah because again this
bishop on a7
is this kind of piece which is good
potentially very powerful but also
potentially
uh can be really one day out of play
yeah i still would prefer white here
because
uh i think the biggest problem i have
here is that i would like to go rook a
a but it loses material to the after d5
yeah
so and then if black plays d5 which is
also another
idea himself then e5 and this bishop on
a7 is
is now very poor piece yeah all of a
sudden
it it will become a tempo game because
if i get if i get some kind of rook a8
c6 bishop v8 and somehow f6 i'm
suddenly doing completely fine but i
need to make many moves in a row
yeah yeah mom usually my experience
shows that
when you give one of the players to make
four moves in a row usually he is doing
well yeah
but yeah in practice it doesn't
uh happen very often yeah yeah the
arbiters the arbiters normally intervene
and tell you
and tell you it's not your move yet yes
so
so i mean yeah maybe you're right peter
knight f1 is is okay even if of course
has to be
i mean my question wasn't even that my
question was why hasn't
been played yet i guess because he wants
b5 knight c4 those ideas with b6 they
also look
quite tempting yeah i mean they might be
yeah you you're
i'm just not gonna the italian you have
complete control from this moment on
because alireza did play b5 and
yeah i mean it's also tempting because a
b b for instance we are trying to go
rookie 80 but after even after rook 8
there is no threat really yeah
i mean not yet no maybe d5 starts
happening in some cases but i'm not sure
but let's see let's say a b even if of
course you don't have to but then you
will always have to be
to to be careful about ba so let's say
it takes
rook e8 and now maybe some tactical
i'm okay let's say uh what is black's
next move
uh is he i'm wondering if i can actually
if if i can actually play d5 if you if
you do nothing for one more move
maybe i i want ed and c4 still the same
idea but i will be taking with the
knight and then after c4 i will be
playing knight f4 and that's a lot more
active than the position
yeah obviously yeah obviously so in any
case white will probably
make some move here because he's forced
to at minimum
by uh the rules of chess so let's think
what
what kind of move can be done here
knight c4 ed4 yeah b6 bishop takes b6
yeah we can try but i don't think it
works out yeah i don't see i don't see
how it works yeah take stakes
b6 bishop b6 and uh yeah if they there's
that the
the pawn on e4 is saying if the pawn e4
wasn't hanging it would be very
very pleasant for white maybe but but it
is
so probably d5 probably let's say d5
here
d5 rookie 7
d5 through k7 and the
knight c4 what else knight c4
here this is where we got to and and
then i i wasn't quite sure
what we are doing here with the white
pieces because
if you allow me to play b7 b6 i think
yeah i shouldn't normally allow i mean i
have knight a5 but you have at minimum b
should be six yeah
at least yes so and then i cannot take
the pawn on b7 because of rook b8
yeah so let's see but yeah
b6 so uh b6 b66 is very double-edged
so i mean i would even say it's yeah it
looks very good for black yeah
if b66 so white probably shouldn't play
d5 yeah
because here it looks really good yeah
so then then the question is what's the
rookie one maybe which is maybe the
reason you should including
we shouldn't be including a b but still
bishop b6 is it such a big deal
yeah exactly it's like if you play
knight c4 here the screen takes b5
but even the same position after he
takes d4 is maybe playable
[Music]
i don't know what we've achieved i'm not
quite sure if b5 was the best move but
let's see
yeah let's see anyway it's my fault
because it was my proposal so but let's
see
so let's go let's check the other games
let's see what is magnus doing so he
doesn't want to sacrifice
no he played he played rookie seven uh
playing
uh playing very patiently so far and not
not willing to
party so his idea is obviously to go 95
and then rook eb7
in some situations in some situations
will be will be a new resource available
to him sure i wouldn't stand i wouldn't
manage to uh you know to resist yeah i
mean rook takes c3
of course in in blitz game no doubt at
all but even in classical probably
i would it just looks so aesthetically
nice black's position after taking 95
albus black squares immediately you know
you have this
wolf under some games
in your mind etc etc but
maybe objectively rookie 7 is also okay
but
and also interestingly magnus has
finally started uh burning time so it
did feel like he was definitely stealing
his preparation up to
rook b8 and maybe even a6 although a6 is
already i was i was less sure but
rookie 7 is is something he has for the
first time today he
uh spent some serious time on uh eight
and a half minutes on
one don't know so but it feels to me
that
white should have i mean some
some ideas here i mean to me frankly it
looks a bit slow yeah because even
after 95 i can already put my bishop on
c6 for instance yeah
trying to prevent uh rook b7 and uh
or even b3 sometimes it doesn't look so
clear to me
yeah young sister chooses knight g3
which is a very very concrete move uh
obviously the threat now is knight f5
but yeah i'm not quite sure he really
wants to take on h5 yeah
yeah this is the question yeah yeah more
like he wants 94 knight f5
yeah nobody nobody cares about the h5
pawn here
and here 94 maybe i mean at least it's
very principle
move if it works